so kim uh keeping up with the
kardashians after 14 years
is off the air now it's car grey's
anatomy
gray's an adam what's the longest
running show is it grey's anatomy grey's
anatomy is still on
and uh that's great that my wife has
just started
she's she's never seen an episode i got
to sit through [ __ ] 16 seasons
of [ __ ] grey's anatomy because i just
listen to doctors
talk uh under [ __ ] the the the
soundtrack of the day
wait a second so your wife has never
seen an episode i've never [ __ ] heard
so much snow patrol in the
background oh they were big snow patrol
that that made them famous
let's oh yeah let's work we forgot to
work it girls the kid kardashians are
working girls
[Music]
you've ever seen two morning show hosts
dance with their ass and their gut it's
what it is dance with my stomach and you
dance with your big
fat [ __ ] ass your ass is [ __ ] up
my wedgie ass because we forgot to want
to give you guys a little extra things
to move your monkey to
kim kardashian's our work girl thank you
seth
for 14 years of keeping up
yes yes yes you've collectively
it's a great job but you've collectively
ruined the hearts and minds of our youth
the suicide rate is increasing because
of your show
yeah i mean you guys have had a lot of
plastic surgery done
you've gone through a bunch of
basketball players we've been with you
through the ups and the downs and the
through lines we
america has just really grown up with
you
i mean kim kardashian is [ __ ] hot
though yeah before now she's gotten a
little bit too much plastic surgery
but like maybe after like her third
plastic surgery like this i mean she's
just a [ __ ] smoke show cause
kim kardashian if she was walking on
third avenue
she would make you put your apartment
off the market back on the market off
the market
back tomorrow yeah i [ __ ] put it
right back on and take it right back off
to you kimmy k
yeah so they're going off the air 14
seasons of kardashians they're all
multi-billionaires
were they good for america were they not
who cares it doesn't matter actually it
doesn't matter they work and they work
and khloe kardashian is definitely o.j
simpson's daughter it's a guy yeah yeah
so yeah
just what can you do sir just you gotta
understand
you know everybody likes to [ __ ] and
blame everybody for their problems
take care of your [ __ ] at home solve
your own [ __ ] problems okay it's like
i love people like they're you know
cause obviously i'm kidding the
kardashians ruined
society or they they made my kid do this
no they didn't you did because for being
a shitty [ __ ] parent pay attention to
your [ __ ] kids
and do your best and shut the [ __ ] up
and stop trying to blame everybody else
for your
issues okay you and only you can solve
your issues and you are responsible
for how you interact and you're
responsible for your reactions to
every single thing that happens in your
life so stop blaming everybody else
you [ __ ] losers you're absolute
losers if you blame anybody else for
your problems
but yourself chrissy steel pipe so there
you go that's steel pipe chrissy that
was
also um that was also a verbatim because
he didn't get a chance because he had to
go do something with the baby
but that was supposed to be his rnc
speech at the republican national
convention
yeah i could yeah i should have been a
good speech i should have been there
yeah charlie kirk i've been dming you
and you don't read my messages
yeah my sneakers look like cleats what
can you do